plenty of action tonight in the US
Senate on illegal immigration but is
anything actually being accomplished
chief congressional correspondent Mike
Emanuel is on Capitol Hill tonight with
the breakdown of a busy day good evening
Mike well Brett good evening the Senate
voted on multiple daca plans but it all
fell short of the 60 s vote threshold
with just 39 senators voting in favor of
a ticket or leave it pitch this is it in
a sense only plan that can become law
because the president said he would sign
it Judiciary Chairman Chuck Grassley led
the plan favored by the White House and
leading Republicans it met the
president's four pillars provide a
12-year path to citizenship for some 1.8
million so-called dreamers authorized 25
billion dollars for border security more
manpower and a wall limit family based
migration to the nuclear family and
phased out the Visa Lottery system the
president's made clear and I strongly
agree that any legislation must also
treat the root causes and reform legal
immigration and it must also include
common-sense steps to ensure the safety
of the American people
president Trump shared his thoughts on
Twitter this morning while the
Republicans and Democrats in Congress
are working hard to come up with a
solution to daca they should be strongly
considering a system of merit-based
immigration so that we will have the
people ready willing and able to help
all those companies moving into the USA
the Senate Democratic leader accused the
president of meddling there's only one
reason why the Senate will be unable to
reach a bipartisan solution to daca
president trouble there was also a
bipartisan plan negotiated by 22
senators which was attacked by the White
House including a veto threat and the
president warning it would be a total
catastrophe and the Department of
Homeland Security warranty would be
quote the end of immigration enforcement
in America at the release was so
over-the-top and inflammatory not
factual that I don't think it's gonna be
taken that seriously we're the center of
the United States where the article one
branch we don't have to play mother
mae-eye with anybody to make policy one
of the architects of the plan vented his
frustration with some of the president's
inner circle mr. president listen to the
American people and lead us in Congress
and all will turn out
if you turned this agenda over the most
extreme people on this issue you're
going to fail like a bomb and bush the
Senate Republican whip called this week
dedicated to solving this issue a missed
opportunity presents generously offered
a pathway to citizenship for 1.8 million
daca recipients and daca eligible people
so it's disappointing but we're not
going to give up because the deadline is
still March the fifth and the clock is
ticking Senate Republican leader sound
reluctant deport burn more time on this
issue White House officials say the
fight now shifts to the house where they
believe leadership is getting closer to
getting enough votes for the more
conservative plan from House Judiciary
Chairman Bob Goodlatte a plan they say
has a lot of what the president wants
Brett yeah but quickly Mike I mean if
the House passes that that is more
conservative than the Grassley bill was
that failed today it would appear to
have a lot of problems in the United
States Senate it's just a question of
how badly they want a deal or whether
this becomes a 20-18
midterm election issue grab Mike Emanuel
out on the hill Mike thanks